the 1.6 billion dollar Mega Millions
jackpot has one winning ticket the
winning numbers for the biggest jackpot
in the US history are twenty eight
seventy five sixty two sixty five and
five the single ticket with that
combination was sold in South Carolina
another thirty six tickets across the
country won a million dollars second
prize so it's still worth checking your
tickets this morning but the cash payout
for the big prize is a staggering nine
hundred and four million smackeroos
that's a lot of money mark Strassmann is
outside lottery headquarters in Columbia
South Carolina mark good morning to you
good morning and what a wild night it
was one official grand prize winner
someone who's now about a billion
dollars wealthier than they were 24
hours ago we do not know the name of the
winner and we may never know South
Carolina lottery law allows its winners
to remain anonymous but whoever they are
they have three months to come to this
state lottery office walk up to those
windows with their ticket to claim the
jackpot tonight's Mega Millions jackpot
is a record-breaking 1.6 billion dollars
the lucky winner defied odds of one in
300 million on that mega maaan number is
five a winning ticket has been sold
right here in South Carolina I'm trying
to figure out who won the Mega Millions
the winner at that moment millions of
people across the country held on to a
billion dollar dream great have been a
week people I got the winning numbers
I've been ready since 1967 and I'm 67
years old so about time at one point on
Tuesday California is selling 540 Mega
Millions tickets a second at Bluebird
liquor and Hawthorne the line Raptor
the store I played to win I don't play
for fun
there was only one jackpot ticket sold
so here's where the rest of the mega
revenue goes 50 percent goes to the
prize pool while the other 50% is
allocated to state retailer Commission's
vendor fees and special causes in South
Carolina lottery funds are used to
support a variety of educational
programs 82% of funds go to college
education and scholarships the rest goes
to programs for grades K through 12 it's
unclear exactly where in South Carolina
the ticket was bought but it's a little
bit of good news for a state still
recovering from Hurricane Florence South
Carolina's governor estimated that
hurricane caused 1.2 billion dollars in
damage to the state that's still three
hundred million dollars less than the
value of the winning ticket the owner of
the store that sold the winning jackpot
ticket will get a $50,000 prize lottery
officials may release the name of that
store by noon today and for all of you
who want a second crack at instant
lottery wealth
there's the Powerball jackpot tonight
the jackpot stands at six hundred twenty
million dollars still not too shabby 620
million bucks I guess I can do this yeah
you absolutely can it dreams come on
last night
one can try yes but you're still buying
us pizza yes that I can get no pepperoni
though just cheese